[Musique]
gc smollett interprète un chanteur gay
dans la série inférieure
une fiction qui se déroule dans le monde
du hip hop et qui en est à sa cinquième
saison
la vie de l'acteur noir est ouvertement
gay bascule de 29 janvier dernier
lorsqu'il affirma la police de chicago
avoir été insulté et attaqué par deux
hommes blancs portant des lunettes de
ski
c'est dans ce quartier qu'ils auraient
frappé ce mot lot à coups de poings et
de pieds avant de déverser de l'eau de
javel sur lui et de lui passer une corde
autour du cou avant de prendre la fuite
dans un contexte très chargé sur les
questions raciales et sur la place des
minorités aux états unis bien vite des
stars de hollywood et des politiciens
dénonce cet ignoble acte homophobe et
raciste
tout comme le maire de chicago qui ne
tolère pas ce genre d'horreur la
jeunesse
en entrevue exclusive de semaine plus
tard l'acteur donne des détails sur
l'agression est saine l'un d'eux m'a
frappé dit il en me disant que c'était
le pays de maga l'acronyme de mecs
america grid guen le slogan de donald
trump
de quoi exacerber davantage la
polarisation politique au pays
sauf que pendant ce temps l'enquêté se
poursuit et la police est capable
d'identifier ces deux suspects premier
problème ils ne sont pas blancs mais
bien afro-américains et bizarrement l'un
de ses deux frères connais je sis dans
lot et a même fait de la figuration dans
la série en période après avoir fouillé
leur appartement on y trouve des masques
de l'eau de javel est un magazine qui
aurait pu servir à composer cette
présumée lettre de menaces contre small
est envoyée avant l'agression
alors que l' enquête progresse des
soupçons s'accumulent dans cette affaire
la police découvre alors que les deux
frères auraient reçu 3500 $ de justice
man lebt pour commettre cette fausse
agression
le comédien s'est rendu ce matin à la
police de chicago
pour le commissaire avec cette
machination smollett a trahi toute la
ville de chicago et à profiter de la
colère et du racisme pour promouvoir sa
carrière tout cela n'était qu'un coup
publicitaire dit il car le comédien
était insatisfait de son salaire alors
qu'il déclarait larmoyant probablement
un rôle de composition selon la police
qu'il souhaitait que justice soit faite
la paire santé par just as an il sait
maintenant que s'il est reconnu coupable
j'ai six mallettes risque de troquer les
tapis rouge pour la grisaille d'une
cellule de prison où ils pourraient
croupir jusqu'à trois ans ici frédéric
arnould radio canada mon frère